people are like no no no I'm I'm this
hyper rationalist I've researched
evidence and it's clear there is no such
thing as Paras psychology have you
researched any of the people that I've
mentioned maybe you're curs if it was me
I would spend two weeks just going into
their papers and if I had questions like
oh I think there are some fundamental
flaws and how they did this analysis
yeah I would contact the author totally
so I would say like they may say yeah I
read their studies I'm like but but
there are flaws did you contact rert
sheldrake and ask him about it no like
is that are you truly interested in the
subject or are you just saying that
you're are you just trying to put on
some face so that you can be a member of
this aidite cohort of Urbane
sophisticates it's it's exactly it's
your it's your carrying card in a
certain social milu yeah like they don't
want to lose that card of their of their
membership of the enlightened
intelligencia that's what they care
about exactly